hey there everybody and welcome back to
GameSpot's continuing live coverage of
e3 2014 I'll be your host for the
morning here on the GameSpot stage I'm
Sean McGuinness and I am joined by Evan
Richard and Jared some of the folks
behind one of a game with a title that
can only be described as amazing and
that game of course is broforce guys
thanks for joining us on the stage yeah
absolutely so we're running a little bit
behind so we're just gonna jump straight
into the game we're gonna skip all the
intros let's check out a little bit of
broforce
for anybody who's not heard of the game
how would you describe this how does it
live up to the title playing broforce
you start off playing as a ram a rambo
like character rambro and you're gonna
be in like this kind of terrorist
infested jungle fighting away lots of
explosions liberating POWs and kind of
unlocking all these new characters and
yeah I don't like discovering all the
different attacks and abilities as you
go along cool so we've obviously got two
players going on here so coop support
yeah I'm going to assume as a big part
of the game
yeah the game can be single but it
really shines when you've got two or
more players cuz you're a lot of it is
about saving each other as you as you
die and then you can never resurrect
your teammates and that's a lot lower
camaraderie comes out of that single
parents you know there's still a lot of
explosions for a lot of Ag stuff but if
you want to play with friends on a couch
like that that's really where we
envisage this gaming play we are
developers of this and a lot of practice
how so
you guys died almost instantly there no
offense
how do you how would you so how would
you describe the overall difficulty of
this game basic it it looks like it's
pretty tough it's I think it's as tough
as you want it to be
it looks like a run-and-gun it looks
like a kind of contra a middle suck type
game but you really don't have to walk
in fact running in like all guns blazing
is kind of the hardest way to play the
game it's kind of Judaism as fun as well
so it's really it's up to you how
difficult you want it to be if you play
very cautiously you can get through the
game slowly and most people should be
able to do that but these guys they've
been playing it so much no it's like
it's more fun being reckless
so with a game like broforce humor is
gonna be a big part of it
can you describe this just a sense of
style and the sort of level of comedy
that you guys are going for here 80s and
90s like action films like escape from
New York a lot of them had these kind of
very like tough like pro-america kind of
themes like right you know having like
ripped biceps tearing off your shirt and
then like killing some bad guys and
that's kind of you know like modern
modern takes a mega action films like
bit more serious and like light handed
with their approach on that and it's
kind of going back and watching
real cloth because it's kind of absurd
and then we wanted that to come across
in the game that there's that it's kind
of it's this ridiculous thing to go in
and solve all your problems with guns
but like it's awesome so if you guys
want to send us questions feel free to
submit questions in the live chat on
gamespot.com or you can send them my way
on twitter my twitter name is at s
McGuinness we try to throw that on the
screen right here so you can send them
my way so far not a question more of a
statement
AMD really fast says that beard is
glorious and granted all three of you
have beards but I think we know what the
real glorious beard is No thank you guys
I don't think these guys respect me if I
go there we go we've got a good shot of
the beard right here let's see
all right the gaming baby is asking
co-op online local yep so we've got at
the moment the game is on Steam early
access and there's like an early version
of the clock up there you can play
online you can thank the co-operative
game online and we're still working on
it like there's been a few it was it's a
bit tough getting a game that's got such
a lot of like things going on on the
screen
or a pipeline but slowly and putting out
all the problems by 3:00
yeah let's talk about your guys's
approach to early access how does the
game compare like now as it stands today
versus when you guys submitted it what's
what's changed so okay we haven't been
in early access that long we were in
like the game had like a payable version
right from like like October or August
2012 the game is as it really those
early versions are so rough there's the
graphics are really simple there's far
fewer pros far fewer places you can go I
think it's a little polished experience
now like recently we've been adding some
more pros and like each each month we're
trying to have a bit of an update some
you know hopefully some new characters
or new enemies when he faces to explode
liberate jazz from hell and the chat is
asking about the overall length of the
game roughly how much how much content
is there and is there much replayability
so right now
about a two-hour campaigns it's
relatively short there they are death
meant to the deathmatch mode with
fighting against each other and like
seeing how RAM broken is like map Rover
or Robocop
and that can be fun with you if you like
you're competitive country games there's
a couple other competitive modes that
we're kind of got in there and kind of
working on so there's I think there's a
bit of replayability I think it's gonna
get more as we go along so never let us
come to the game so yeah you can make
like levels and share them online my
Steam also because it's such like a
large amount of pros especially when
you're playing like warfare multiplayer
there's a lot of permutations all right
so we're actually getting a lot of
questions about the ps4 version of the
game because you're checking out PC
right here but there are other versions
how do they compare overall I think on
the showroom floor there's a ps4 version
of it it's pretty comparable right now
it's like it was a it was a quite a
quite difficult getting it like
immediately on to the people we had very
little time but it worked pretty good I
think people me enjoying it so it looks
like we're gonna have a like it at least
as good version there's a chance there
might be like some special like
unlockable stuff on the ps4 version
we're still figuring that out well you
got to do is if you have three players
the LED light bar has to be red white
blue yellow America definitely
so there's rumbling and yeah I'm red
right um yeah it's just flashing red
white and blue constantly that that's a
free idea you can use that loyalty bear
let's
all right so we've just got another
minute or two here I'll try to throw in
oh look what these guys made nearly
finished the game well the the demo one
more question here we actually had I
lost the name of the question here but
kind of a theoretical one if Microsoft
asks you to make an xbox one version
would you guys be willing to do that um
I'm not actually too sure what we've
discussed with Sony to be honest III
want the game to be on couches I'm
happier happy with it being on a couch
attached to Microsoft thinks I don't
know when if that's gonna happen at the
moment we're focusing on like Sony and
putting our eggs in that basket but yeah
I spend tend to be correct right sure I
hope good one everyone's coming all
right guys well we would definitely
appreciate you coming by and demoing a
little bit of broforce it look it looks
crazy and silly and ridiculous in all
the right ways
I'll be sure to check it out myself so
there you have it that's the team behind
broforce we're going to cut